have you had pranks go awry or maybe
it's or you're in it and it's not
happening the way you want it to go yeah
that's all that's every day that's every
time you shoot a prank yeah
um
going awry means different things to
different people so going awry can be
great yeah going awry yes I'm in the
going awry business
uh but it not
um getting anywhere the prank being a
dud happens constantly you have to shoot
so much more than actually airs I think
bad trip probably we shot
you're the final movie you're only
seeing like 30 percent of the stuff we
should right right well that proves my
the thing I've been saying forever which
is to me
um most and it doesn't just apply to
Comedy but when you see something that
you really like it's all about what you
didn't show because I do think there are
people that would look at your stuff and
think yeah that just anytime you go out
and do anything it's all going to be
magic all the time no
90 of us
unwatchable
garbage trash
Jesus Take It Easy you okay
I still have those pills are they handy
can you get to them
that's not how it works so in a few
weeks it's gonna kick in man
I wish that you would get on a mood
stabilizer so powerful that it was a
giant pill and like a horse they had to
put it in a tube and blow it into your
mouth
why why do you want that for me because
it would it would just be funny for me
it's like it's time it's time Eric
you're like oh you open your mouth
and they come in with a big tube and
they get a veterinarian to do it
or else they have a dart gun that they
and they chase you with it and you're
trying to get away
I mean get him in the Carotid like I'm
harambe or something I got a
three-year-old in my hand whipping them
around
yeah I'm with it I'm okay with that I
wish drinking was good for you I wish it
would that be great it would solve oh my
problem it was feel rich with vitamins
and antioxidants yeah turns out ethanol
is poison yes it's concentrated poison
I'm like oh yeah that's a problem yeah I
also wish uh regular exercise shortened
your life yes
well I jog I also do weights three day
times a week and I try and get my heart
rate up at least six times a week okay
we gotta stop that are you drinking
well water oh God
no no no no no
sugary fruity rum drinks
you need to drink so many of them that
when you wake up in the morning you wish
you were dead
you wish that you were dead he's got a
pina colada machine
you're gonna need this back in the day
doctors would smoke cigarettes in this
office yeah while they were talking to
you about your lung X-ray that's insane
you know what's crazy though there are
these people like
um like Winston Churchill obviously an
example of that guy that health nut that
he he hated vegetarians he called them
bean eaters
and and uh but um uh he he ate and he
drank constantly yeah and uh which all
he'd eat was like roast beef and
Yorkshire pudding yeah and he's he's
he's drinking and he's power smoking
cigars all day long dies at like 94. are
you serious a really long time it's not
fair all these friends of his around him
were you know uh saying it Winston
please get a hold of yourself man and uh
my one of my favorite quotes is Peter
O'Toole one of the greatest uh you know
uh actors of all time uh late in life
um they said what are you doing now that
you've retired like sir O'Toole because
he made a you know ignited and he said
they said what are you up to these days
because you're acting less what are you
doing and he said how do you spend your
time and he said I uh I attend the
funerals of friends of mine who took
exercise
he's a legendary drinker
just drank his way through the 60s like
all those guys and George Burns cigars
until he was like 101 years old yeah so
what does that mean is it all genetics
is it just a genetic crap shoot yeah
they do or should I start doing HGH now
and all crazy you should Dwayne The Rock
Johnson kind of drugs I should um that's
a myth It's All Pure what's going on
he's 75 years old no what do what do I
do well uh all joking aside I do think
it's been shown that the uh that the
cigarette thing is probably a gene
meaning there are people genetically
they don't they haven't I don't think
they've isolated that Gene but there are
people who can smoke and they are much
less less less less likely to get any
kind of lung cancer my guess is that
Keith Richards is like one of those
people you know it's insane to inhale
the combustion of tobacco yeah
steadily steadily since for you know
since 1957 I think Keith Richards
started smoking in the crib and then uh
and then and then yeah but what about
all the drinking Winston Churchill was
like he was like Jack Kerouac he was
like
that's another thing too where I think
he was drinking throughout the day but
not uh no I don't he was not Jack
Kerouac he was not a blackout drunk he
was not drinking and
um like that he was drinking in a
different way he was drinking in this
sophisticated English imperialist way
he was drinking It's Five O'Clock
Somewhere is his quote he would drink
gin like all day wouldn't he I don't but
I don't think he was I don't think it
was glug glug glug drinking that's all
I'm saying is and I also think it helps
when you're an imperial power okay
when when you're you know colonialists
they're just uh there's something about
that system that preserves the uh the
organs
it doesn't make any sense no everything
I'm saying so should I take over a
country yes should I take over like a
small Caribbean island make a monocrop
yes and if you um if you exploit their
resources for your good Cobalt yeah
exactly and then underpay them yeah um
you can drink all you want oh and you'll
live forever
I like the way this is going I'm off to
Papa New Guinea you are an essentially
good person but I keep convincing you to
get Edge fund yep
I'm a slum Lord uh yeah it expired
Zoloft yeah and then colonize other
countries for your own good all right
that's all you take out of this thing
foreign